Donald Trump was defeated by Ted Cruz in
Iowa's Republican caucus yesterday still
here's the kind of interesting part mr.
Trump was kind enough to make himself
available to us tonight
by phone he called into the show show to
talk about it don't laugh like that's
made-up that's real Donald Trump is
calling right now he's on the line
apparently he's on the right now this is
fantastic
hello hello oh hello mr. Trump it's
Conan O'Brien and I love you Andy and I
love your studio it's you know it's fact
roaded i love okay well sir I want to
talk to you about this all this love
talk now and last night you were
incredibly gracious last night it didn't
seem like you in your concession speech
you were so nice yeah well you know yes
and once again congratulations to Ted
Cruz you know he did a phenomenal job
and frankly so many of my opponents
could do a really really good job as the
president what it's crazy what you're
saying now this is very surprising it's
a whole new 180 degree different tone
for you what's going on well listen
listen that's because just what I
started seeing things going wrong last
night I took every Zadok I could decide
it out and in the car and milania's
purse I even you know remarkably found
some in the seat cushions of my jet it's
probably going to wear up any second you
think the xanax will wear off any second
yep Kiowa what sir what'd you say
as dead crazy you can't say that they
said I'm going to kick ted cruz's acid
in New Hampshire I am going to beat him
so bad he's going to run home to Canada
and set himself on fire okay listen no
sir I don't think he's going to do that
Coenen fire he'll go up like an old
hotel in New Jersey
you're touching for the insurance money
not that I ever did that twice okay look
that that's enough let's not talk about
this anymore okay
oh yeah also also don't have to really
knock it off stop saying that word okay
fine
all right all right listen screw New
Hampshire screw the Carolinas screw
guam's rule American Samoa and in fact
screw all this about this or I think I
think that's enough I think you've said
enough
you know what screw America we're a
third-rate country give me Russia any
day no that's crazy that's not to sir
don't say that it's true this planet
produces its polluters I'm taking up
opening a casino on Vader so screw okay
thank you very much Donald Trump
you